si vous est passé récemment rue du
docteur paul brousse à paris vous avez
certainement aperçu cet immeuble à
l'architecturé cubique si certains
déplorent l'aspect extérieur l'intérieur
est pourtant bien plus lugubre et
cellules ou des gaz à dormir pour des
étudiants qui n'auraient pas les moyens
de se payer une chambre dans la capitale
à peine trois mètres carrés juste de
quoi s'allonger est tout de même un
loyer de 250 euros par mois c'est une
blague franchement on l'a peint la même
cage sur twitter de nombreux internautes
ont décidé d'interpeller la maire de
paris anne hidalgo alors êtes vous
choqué par les cases à 250 euros créée
par la mairie de paris pour les
étudiants
[Musique]
âgés hyper choqué je trouve ça beaucoup
trop cher vous avez trois mètres carrés
c'est pas une chambre légal de 9 m²
collection maison ou en appartement moi
je trouve ça hyper cher et je trouve ça
même c'est une lumière ça va les rendre
dingue dingue je trouve ça très bizarre
ce même pas bernard moi je suis très
très choquant il faudrait que ce soit
gratuit l extrême limite mais même à ce
que c'est très dur déjà projet étudiant
il est vrai que c'est difficile de se
loger à paris mais là on plus payer leur
faire payer 250 barça devrait être
gratuit par la mairie de paris un projet
encore sans projet et essai c'est une
honte moi surnom de passion d'un chenil
révolte qui mettent des êtres humains
dedans c'est un truc de fou ça devrait
même pas exister ça peut être est ce
parce qu'on dit 250 ou gratuits moi
quand j'ai vu ça la première fois en
ligne à 10 15 ans j'avais dit mais ils
sont complètement fou les chinois ils
dorment les uns sur les autres comme ça
ils ont plus de place sont complètement
fous là vous allez mettre des étudiants
là dedans comme ça dormir un cairote un
clip est un qui vomit un climat charlie
son ca devrait même pas exister tu
t'étais dans quelques secondes
[Rires]
mais non mais quand tu dors tu contrôles
pas dit pas contrôler quand le matin
même pas exister c'est inhumain
normalement les questions près ils ont
une
obligé travail ils ont leur recours à
faire que tu deviens fou n'y a pas de
gars pas de lumière du jour y'a rien à
perdre gratuit paris gratuits quand même
pas gratuite ça de voir féliciter ça
c'est quoi l'on retrouve c'est une très
bonne idée c'est la soeur qui a plein
d'étudiants qui n'ont pas les moyens de
se loger à paris laisse une école
gratuite qui donne des cours gratuits ça
coûte moins de 150euro moi j'ai regardé
cet après midi à paris vous n'avez rien
en dessous de 400 euros donc c'est quand
même une économie considérable et c'est
des logements temporaires et c'est une
école qui offre une formation gratuite
franchement bravo m mais bon oui aux
impôts guillaume pivot
rien 400e rotariens dans paris pourquoi
pourquoi nos impairs servirait pas s'il
va aider nos études mains des logements
sociaux a reproché ses délires est
temporairement à la fin c'est des
logements temporaires n'ont pas de
logement suis désolé énergie guillaume
d'abord c'est cautionner par la mairie
de paris mais son prix si c'est un
projet privé donc c'est cautionner par
la mairie et c'est une honte ce sont des
êtres humains ce ne sont pas des animaux
même si c'est temporaire c'est
incroyable ils vont devenir notre
recrutement la lumière garder la lumière
ça va briser leur cerveau briser leur
projet brille sur un que vous dit non
mais c'est guillaume du brésil aux idées
et honteux série entre amis reda briseur
de rêves les étudiants d'aujourd'hui
c'est notre avenir mais on en donne de
l'argent c'est bien simple rien c'est un
truc reims ne soit que rien mais d
les déchets